back home my friends call me nicknames
such as the giant clam go clam queen oh
the mother of clams this is because
every time I see them I talk non-stop
about giant clams all day every day
giant clams are this massive and
colorful shout marine animals the
largest of its kind just look at this
shell the biggest ricotta individual was
four and a half feet long and weigh
about 550 pounds that is almost as heavy
as three baby elephants South Pacific
legends once described giant clams as
man-eaters they would line way on the
seabed to trap unsuspecting divers a
story goes that a diver had lost his
legs while trying to retrieve a pole
from a giant clam I thought really so
out of curiosity I did an experiment
using myself as bait
I carefully placed my hand into the
clams mouth and waited hmm I still have
my hand it seems that these gentle
giants would rather retreat and protect
your fleshy bodies than feet on me
so much for this killer clam is
unfortunately the reality is we are the
giant clams biggest threat considered a
delicacy throughout the western Pacific
and Indian Oceans giant clams have been
traditionally finished as seafood
fishermen are particularly interested in
their adductor muscles which are organs
that host the two shells together like a
hinge just for their muscles giant clams
were almost hunted to extinction between
the 1960s and 1980s clam shells are also
popular in the ornamental tree as jury
and for display in the South China Sea
fishermen went out of their way to
collect fossilized clam shells by
digging through large areas of coral
reefs these were later cast and so as so
called ivory handicrafts in China
a giant clams did our life not safe from
us it's a calamity with the spotlight on
more charismatic marine animals such as
the whales and coral reefs it is easy to
forget that other marine life needs our
help too my fascination with the giant
clams got me started on the conservation
research to fill in the knowledge gaps
on the ecology and behavior one of the
discoveries that we made was that giant
clams could walk across the seafloor yes
you heard me right they can walk to find
out we placed numerous baby clams on a
grid now watch what happens over 24
hours we think that walking is important
for getting away from predators and
finding meats for breeding well it can
be hard to imagine any movement in this
enormous animals giant clams up to 400
pounds can still walk they just move
slower during my PhD I discovered more
secrets about the giant clams but there
was something missing in my work I found
myself asking why should people care
about conserving giant clams other than
myself of course it turns out that giant
trends have giant impact on coral reefs
this multitasking clams are reef
builders food factories shelters for
streams and crabs and water filters all
wrote in one in a nutshell giant clams
play a major contributing role as
residents of their own reform and just
having them around
keeps the reef healthy and because they
can live up to a hundred years old
giant clams make vital indicators of
coral reef health so when giant clams
start to disappear from coral reefs the
absence can serve as an alarm bell for
scientist
start paying attention similar to the
canary in a coalmine but giant clams i
endangered the largest clam in the world
is facing the threat of extinction with
more than 50% of the wild population
severely depleted and the ecological
benefits of having giant clams on coral
reefs are likely to continue
only if populations are healthy making a
conservation paramount so I stand here
today to give a voice to the giant clams
because I care a whole lot for this
amazing animals and they deserve to be
careful it is time for the giant clams
to step out of their shells and show the
wall that they too can be the heroes of
the oceans thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]